jacob charges nine dollars an hour to
paint the graph below shows the number
of hours he spent painting different
rooms of one house
how much did jacob charge for painting
the living room
so here's the graph this is a picture
graph or pictograph and it shows us how
much time jacob spent painting different
rooms of a house
one super important thing is this little
key right here that tells us each of
these paint buckets is three hours of
time
so we're asked about the living room
so on the graph we can find where it
says living room and see how many
buckets
and remember each of these buckets
equals
three hours of time
so he spent three hours plus another
three hours so he spent a total of six
hours
painting the living room
but the question asks us
how much did jacob charge
well jacob charges nine dollars for
every hour
and he worked for six hours so he
charged nine dollars six times nine
dollars for each of the six hours he
worked
which is a total
of 54
dollars
jacob charged a total of 54. to paint
the living room